more than 40 million Americans are
waiting to learn if President Biden's
student loan forgiveness plan will
survive the Supreme Court challenge
hundreds rallied outside of the high
court yesterday
urging the justices to uphold this
program however during arguments
conservative justices expressed deep
concerns about the plan
Jan Crawford is at the Supreme Court
with more on the story in Jan based on
what we're hearing some of the excuse me
what we've heard hearing some of the
Justice say this loan forgiveness
program does not look so good to survive
the challenge it was a tough day I think
for the White House yesterday Gail I
mean those conservatives say they were
skeptical that President Biden has this
power to single-handedly forgive upwards
of half a trillion dollars in student
loans that's up to 43 million people who
could get some kind of loan forgiveness
95 percent of all people with student
loans and you know as Chief Justice John
Roberts said when you're talking that
kind of money it affects that many
Americans most people would think that's
something for Congress to act on now on
the flip side the liberal justices did
try to argue that this 2003 law gave the
administration power to act during
National emergencies like covet but
still I mean those conservatives are
still in a clear six to three majority
so like I said it was it was a tough day
but you know there was I think there was
a wrinkle and so the administration
still does have have some hope and that
focused on whether the challengers these
Six republican-led States and two
borrowers have cleared this procedural
hurdle to even bring the case in the
first place now two of the conservative
justices Brett Kavanaugh and Amy Coney
Barrett they both raised questions about
that and I thought both of them were at
times kind of hard to read but we will
know by the end of June that's when the
court is expected to make this decision
and in the meantime this entire loan
forgiveness program is on hold as are
the payments student loan payments also
on hold until after a decision in this
case Vlad
all right Jan to be continued thank you
very much